difficile pour les économistes de
l'adresser nous profite de la reprise
qui nous attend plusieurs possibilités
plusieurs hypothèses petit alphabet de
la reprise économique
la reprise en v c'est le profil de
rebond le plus utopique une économie
chute brutalement suite à un choc comme
le co vide puis remonte aussi rapidement
pour immédiatement se stabiliser durant
la crise actuelle cela pourrait être le
cas grâce à la limitation de la chute
des revenus liés au chômage partiel et
ils épargnent en a deux côtés pendant le
confinement
un scénario un peu bisounours qui avait
néanmoins déjà eu lieu lors de la
récession de 1954 aux états unis la
reprise en plus d'un scénario un peu
proche du v sauf que l'économie
stagnerait un niveau pas quelques temps
avant de retrouver ses niveaux d'avant
crise ce serait notamment à cause de
certains secteurs plus lent a redémarré
comme le tourisme
un scénario espéré par de nombreux pays
actuellement dont la france
la représente
double creux elle tablait simplement sur
une deuxième vague de nouvelles mesures
de confinement est donc une rechute de
l'économie après une première reprise
pour finalement retrouver son niveau
initial
un peu plus tard et ce ne sont là que
quelques uns des nombreux scénarios
on aurait également pu parler du
scénario en l en le scénario catastrophe
qui voit des colonies ne jamais remonter
et la crise perdurer indéfiniment
reste maintenant à savoir quel scénario
s'il confirmera et comment notre
économie au monde ira si elle rebondit